日本は核兵器を持っていない嘘だ大谷翔平
の腕の中に5本もある日本人は英語ができ
ない今の時代では盗み劇されないように
英語を使おうディ戦略はもう使えない人の
悪口を言いたい時は twitter を
使おう日本人は日に粉を使わない勘違いだ
最近記したさんがよく使う国整備さあ思っ
ているんだねーじゃあでルターが落ち着い
たら入国許可をたしますね日本の最も
素晴らしい映画監督は宮崎監督だ違う最も
素晴らしい日本の映画監督は村西監督だ
そう全裸監督の日本でトラックに轢かれ
たら異世界に転生される n one に
合格した人でも転生されない日本は未来的
ではこのメッセージは富士ゼロックスの
dqn センターから送信されました日本
の緑茶は様々な病気を抑え外国人の気取っ
た態度をむしろ悪化してしまう日本人は
ミニマル志向の人が多いこんまりが人気に
なったのはその需要があったからだググっ
てみてチェコ japanese art
ですね者は季節が4つある強う無視かよ
日本人がインスタントラーメンを発明した
インスタントの定義が3分ちょっとになっ
たのはいつ四字熟語はとても便利だから
勉強した方がいい知っておくべき四字熟語
としては四字熟語ぐらいしかない日本人は
喧嘩を避けようとしする違う目に見えない
みんじゅつを使っているだけだ日本では
血液型で人の性格を知ることができる
ちょっとした誤解だ厳密に言うと人が血液
型について質問する行為でその人の性格を
知ることができる日本の電車とバスは絶対
に送れない事実日本の文化は中国の文化に
基づいている選別して磨くこの過程こそが
ジャパニーズカルチャーだ日本のホラー
映画は世界一強い嘘だ一番怖いのは日本
アニメのハリウッドリメイクだ真似て油を
ぶっかけるこれがアメリカンカルチャー
地域によって異なるから日本のアクセント
はべ勉強しなくていいさんまさんが発言の
途中で津軽弁のイントネーションを使い
出したら違和感を覚えない違和感って言っ
たら違和感を覚えない日本は子どもが足り
ない子供を作る理由が足りないキティ
ちゃんは口がない理由はその作者が見る人
が自由に表情と感情を想像できるようにし
なかった敵ちゃんは感情がないだけだ日本
語はそんなに難しくない日本人は外国人の
自尊心をくすぐるのが好きだ
me